(audience cheering)
One of the hardest parts of "adulting",
I love this new term, "adulting".
Is choosing the perfect place to live
and settle down and call a home. I think,
I was talking about, there are chapters in life
and one of mine is the decision
to move from Los Angeles to New York,
which was very unsettling. But,
I knew that it was the right thing to do.
It was what my daughters needed
and, it just, they're my north star,
so I made the bold move, I took the leap.
I've ended up finding tremendous happiness,
and there are just times in our lives
where something happens that was unexpected,
and we've just got to take that leap.
And our next guest took her own leap of faith,
packed up all of her belongings
and moved from Chicago, Illinois
to the big apple, all by herself.
(energetic music plays)
Hi, I'm Moyo, and I just fulfilled my dream
of moving to New York city. After finishing
my master's degree, I moved back
into my parents' home in Chicago.
And even though I was so happy,
I knew I needed to get out and live my life.
So I decided to come to New York.
I was very set on fall 2020, that was the goal,
but we all know what happened, (laughs)
the pandemic, but, I'm here now. 2021. (laughs)
Since I don't have a lot of space,
all of the shoes, handbags, and clothing
that I'm going to be buying, don't tell my dad (laughs)
I'm going to have to find ways
to be organized in my, my room.
So here's my room. And it was just
the bed and dresser when I came in.
So excited to fill it up and make it very homey.
I just love that it's an open, like, canvas
similar to my experience in New York,
it's an open opportunity, right?
The city of opportunities, so I'm super excited
to decorate it and make it my home.
(audience cheering)
Please welcome, Moyo Areolu.
Moyo Areolu. I have been thinking about you a lot.
It is really nice to meet you in person.
Nice to meet you. (laughs)
Why did you want to come to New York?
I just always wanted to live in New York.
Like it's, it's kinda crazy. (laughs)
It's like an addiction. I just, I love the city.
It's like a city of opportunities.
The diversity, the people, the fashion, the food.
I just love it. (laughs)
You are so beautiful inside and out.
And I know you think that you're just here
so that we could recommend some New York places
that you need to hit, but I couldn't help myself.
I got all up involved in your design and your place,
and I hope you don't mind if we now
surprise you by throwing into
a segment called Designed by Drew.
(audience cheering)
So, that is your space.
Yes.
I did want to put a brand new room
together for you. It's behind these doors.
So God, here we go. Open those doors.
(audience cheering)
I like it.
Can I come in?
Come in! This is your room.
I like it! Can I sit on it?
Now, Everything in here-
if you like it!
No, I like it! I love it.
Is coming to your house and will be installed.
Thank you!
(Audience cheering)
I like it! (laughs)
I like it a lot.
Really?
I do. I really love the color,
But I love the clean look (laughs)
Nerve-racking designing it-
No, I like it!
Before you really get to know someone,
but I did find out some of your likes and dislikes.
Now I'll take you through a couple of reasons
of why I chose certain things.
First of all, I loved the pops of color,
with like, you know, pop art.
Yes!
I just, I wanted colored pillows,
but if you are not feeling as bold that day,
you just remove the pillows and you have
a gorgeous white bed that is alluring and calming.
And, by the way, when you have these spaces,
move stuff around, you know, edit, change,
like, all of the sudden, this completely
went from a lot of color to a lot less color.
Yeah.
I chose this because there is a real discrepancy
out there in the marketplace of basically
couches that can go at the foot of your bed,
nobody wants to sit on a bench.
You don't, I'm sorry. You know what?
It becomes your outdoor closet.
That's true.
But, if you can actually be able to sit comfortably,
then your room can become a social hub
and you're not sitting on your bed.
It's true.
But, most couches are honestly
way too high to be at the foot of your bed.
And this is a problem. So, my suggestion is
you actually trim the legs and lower them.
But the couch at the end of the bed
opens it up to being able to hang out in there.
Right.
And then, when it comes to lamps,
my Cardinal rule is don't go with a metal shade
or an opaque shade. You will not get light from those.
You'll get up and down light, but you,
I am obsessed with shades that actually
let the whole light glow.
Yeah.
And don't get me started on can lighting,
whoever invented can lighting,
I'd like to meet you in a dark alley
(laughs)
by the way, no woman looks good in can lighting.
Do you ever go in the bathroom and you're like
"oh my God, where did all my self-confidence go?"
Can lighting!
(audience laughs)
Because overhead lighting makes you look
like you're starring in your own personal mugshot.
(audience laughing)
So, I also love this headboard
and chose it because I thought
it was unique in the marketplace,
because it goes behind the nightstands.
Ah!
And if you notice, most headboards
would be cut off right here.
Okay! Well, here you go. It's all coming with you!
Thank you!
(audience cheering)
And, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate your time.
(uplifting music plays)